if you get people to stick for one
minute they are much more likely to
watch the whole video if you can't get
them to sick for one minute they're gone
so what happens in that first minute is
really really important so it's either
highlights from the clip that they're
about to watch or it's you giving a
really good intro for it that's why in
the perfect thought leadership template
from build to serve that you have to
lead with a powerful opinion not the hey
guys welcome back it's me I'm so excited
that you're here most people are not
watching your channel So when you say
welcome back they don't welcome back to
what I've never been here before
powerful opinion right out of the gate
or highlights from the clip